hey this is presh tollwacker let s be
the set of all five digit numbers formed
using the digits 1 2 3 4 5 without
repetition
what is the sum of all numbers in s
it's from an old Amazon interview
question
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
so just for fun I asked this question in
chat GPT and I want to let you know it
gave the wrong answer
so while artificial intelligence is a
promising field it's not quite ready to
solve your math homework
so let's work this out the old-fashioned
way
we'll first work it out using computer
code and then I'll show a way to solve
it using a smart calculation
so first computer code
the method is we'll create an array of
all permutations of one two three four
five
so here's computer code in JavaScript
that will do that we have an array where
every single element is a permutation of
the numbers one two three four five
then we will sum all the elements in the
array
so here's code that will do that we'll
Loop through the array sum it up
so here's a visualization
we have every single number that's a
permutation of one two three four five
and we've created a running total
in the end we get the correct answer of
three million 999 and 960.
so this method is great to calculate the
answer however we have to be sure that
our code is correct and that the
computer is not making any sort of goofy
calculation so it's always good to work
this out another way
so let's do a smart calculation
we have the digits going from five to
one and we need to create a five digit
number
so let's suppose that we put five in the
ten thousand spot
what we're going to do is sum all of
these instances of the five in other
words we think about all the possible
numbers that can be made where 5 is in
this spot and we add up 5 multiplied by
10 to the power 4 that many times
so how many numbers are there well we
have four spots that are remaining so we
can take these four digits and arrange
them in four factorial different ways
so the sum of all these instances of 5
will be 5 multiplied by 10 to the power
of 4 multiplied by 4 factorial
now similarly we can put 5 in another
spot what if we put it in the thousands
spot well we have a similar calculation
we have 5 multiplied by 10 to the power
of 3 being in the Thousand spot
multiplied by the four factorial ways
that we can arrange the remaining four
digits but we could also move five over
to the hundred spot so we then need to
add five multiplied by ten squared
multiplied by 4 factorial we move 5 over
to the 10 spot so we have five
multiplied by 10 to the power of one
multiplied by 4 factorial and finally we
have five in the one spot so we add 5
multiplied by 10 to the power of zero
multiplied by 4 factorial
so we can Factor this and we will get
the following expression
now what about the remaining other
digits we can do the same sort of
calculation for the digit four we have 4
multiplied by the sum of these powers of
10 and then we multiply that by 4
factorial the same thing for the digit 3
for the digit 2 and the digit 1.
so we now want to sum all of these
together
so we can first factor out the sum of
these powers of 10
and then we have the sum going from five
to one multiplied by the sum of these
powers of 10 multiplied by 4 factorial
it just remains to calculate this
sum going from five to one is fifteen
the sum of the powers of ten is eleven
thousand one hundred and eleven and then
4 factorial is 24.
so finally we do this calculation and we
get three million 999
000 and 960 and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time